papa c'est un autre sujet celui de la
gestation pour autrui
on voulait vous en parler pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que hier
l'assemblée nationale a voté en première
lecture la reconnaissance de la
filiation d'enfants conçus à l'étranger
par gpa et puis la cour de cassation
après un arrêt cet après-midi alors moi
j'avais compris cet arrêt comme étant
une forme là encore de reconnaissance de
filiation mais laurence rossignol m'a
dit avant le début de l'émission pas du
tout c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
ça alors expliquez nous effectivement on
a quand même le sentiment que la cour de
cassation dit la mère d'intention c'est
à dire en l'occurrence c'est un couple
hétérosexuel a eu recours à la gpa et et
la femme qui pouvaient pas avoir
d'enfant
eh bien elle est quand même reconnu
comme étant la mère de ses deux filles
puisque je crois que ses deux filles
qu'il s'agit qui sont aujourd'hui majeur
effectivement mais c'est une affaire qui
est devant la justice depuis déjà très
longtemps qui a donné lieu à un arrêt de
la cour de cassation qui ensuite a été
déféré devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme
la décision de la cour de cassation a
été cassé par a été sanctionnée par la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
donc ses revenus devant la cour de
cassation
et c'est une affaire effectivement à
laquelle les jeunes et les enfants sont
majeurs elles ont pour le moins ce qu'on
appelle la possession d'état c'est à
dire qu'elles ont été élevés en comme
fille de ceux de sept de ses parents le
père étant le père biologique et la mer
étant effectivement la mère d'intention
est ce que dit la cour de cassation en
l'espèce c'est que d'abord rappelle la
congrégation rappelle dans l'arrêt
menesson que les conventions gpa sont
interdites en droit français mais ne
sont sous le nom de la famille en raison
de la famille que des conventions genre
de gestation pour autrui sont interdites
dans droit français que la filiation
peut être établie par différentes de
différentes manières et que dans le cas
d'une gpa l élite à l'étranger le lien
entre l'enfant et la mère d'intention
d'être établi selon le mode de
reconnaissance qui permettent au mieux
aux juges de contrôler la validité ou et
delà de la convention et d'examiner la
situation particulière de l'enfant et
que c'est l'adoption qui répond le mieux
à cette exigence de contrôler la
situation particulière de l'enfant et
qu'en l'espèce
en l'espèce la transcription est valide
mais c'est en l'espèce à dire que
d'abord c'est un peu une exception
puisque vous prendre mieux
non c'est pas une expérience de
l'exception c'est quand une règle qui
est posée et ses balises est un cas
d'espèce et dans la sphère dans cette
affaire-là rossi normalement il prévoit
là qui a été tabassé comme les plénières
la méditation
mais il était il était assez difficile
probablement après l'accroc paix les
droits de l'homme de prendre une autre
décision que celle ci mais ce que
rappelle pas ce que dit clairement la
cour de cassation c'est que pour autant
la le mode de filiation qui a recommandé
ça reste et demeure l'adoption et donc
il n'y aura pas de transcription
personne ne pourra se prévaloir de
l'arrêt menso pour aller devant le juge
demande et la transcription automatique
d'un acte de filiation établie à
l'étranger
par convention entre une fin d un couple
et une mère porteuse et qu'il faudra
toujours pour l'autre parent puisqu'en
général ya un père biologique dans la
jpa est un père biologique et il ya un
autre parent et que pour l'autre parent
ça reste l'adoption qui est la procédure
qui permet d'établir la filiation
sauf que si j'ai bien compris c'est
justement sur ce principe que a voulu
revenir l'assemblée nationale hier dans
un monde alors même que le gouvernement
nous avait promis la main sur le coeur
que la gpa n'était absolument pas prévu
dans la loi bioéthique
d'où cette gêne très nette de des
patrons de la république en marche or
engagé qui veut carrément faire revoter
les députés nous avons demandé avec le
gouvernement ce qui arrive dans certains
cas qu' une deuxième délibération c'est
à dire qu'à la fin d'examen du texte
on va revoter spécifiquement sur
l'amendement qui a été adopté par ce que
il faut le redire clairement français la
gpa n'est pas dans le projet de loi
bioéthique on a aussi dit qu'une loi de
bioéthique et telle loi qui posait aussi
des interdits et dire on considère qu'il
ya des choses qui au regard de nos
normes éthiques ne doivent pas exister
dans notre pays et c'est le cas de la
gestation pour autrui on considère
qu'elle ne doit pas excéder dans notre
pays passer pour qu elle c'est vrai que
ce discours là il est de moins en moins
audibles contenu du vote des députés ou
de cette décision de la cour de
cassation même si elle est particulière
alors d'abord le vote des députés ils
votaient pas sur la légalisation ou non
de la gpa
il veut tests sur la reconnaissance
d'andrew dans l'état civil français sur
la retranscription dans l'état civil
français d état civil
étrange et des enfants nés de gpa à
l'étranger donc c'est plusieurs
amendements et notamment celles
amendement de monsieur touraine du
député touraine qui a été qui a été
votée du projet oui vous pourrez tout à
fait exact exactement
donc d'abord c'est pas une légalisation
de la gpa on parle de la retranscription
dans l'état français de l'état civil des
enfants nés à l'étranger et et c'est
super en fait parce qu'en fait il ya
trois mille enfants en france
aujourd'hui à peu près selon les les
associations qui gravitent sur le sujet
qui donc n'ont pas leur transcription
dans l'est de l'état civil en ans et
apprend dans l'état civil français
pardon est donc en fait ça pose
énormément de problèmes d'ailleurs la
cod h l'a dit dans le monde qu'elle avec
leur boîte
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
tout à fait dans la langue qu'elle avait
mis à la france quand même puisque ça
pose des problèmes de d'identité pour
l'enfant ça pose des problèmes sur
l'héritage ça peut ça pose tout un tas
de sujets aujourd'hui c'est des enfants
dont ce sont les parents ce sont les
parents en fait ce sont les parents
parce qu'à partir du moment où ils sont
nés ce sont les personnes qui leur ont
sécher leurs larmes qui se sont levés
lannilis parents pour aller le
délibérément hors la loi en ayant
recours à la gpa puisqu'elle est
interdite en france et est donc c'est
pour ça que peut-être il faudrait qu'on
engage un réel débat sur la légalisation
de la gpa en france favorable j'y suis
favorable parce que l'égalisation veut
dire régulation aujourd'hui il ya des
manières de faire la gpa dans certains
pays à l'étranger qui sont inadmissibles
nous chez génération libre on n'a pas ce
que vous êtes aussi pour la légalisation
du cannabis
tout à fait d'accord mais c'était juste
pour jour de la cohérence sur le sur la
manière de légaliser vraiment je le
redis l'égalisation veut dire régulation
et aujourd'hui nous chez génération
libre on a on a longuement travaillé sur
le sujet on a publié un rapport sur le
sujet où on propose une manière de
légaliser la gpa qui soit responsable
qui donne des droits et des devoirs à
chacune des parties prenantes qui
accompagne de manière légale avec un
avocat avec un accompagnement
psychologique toutes les parties
prenantes qui permettent de prendre des
décisions libre et éclairé qui
permettent aussi un petit peu plus de
justice puisque aujourd'hui aller faire
une gpa à l'étranger samedi pour des
personnes qui ont un certain nombre de
moyens de pouvoir le faire je me sens
que quoi qu'il arrive filiation et
reconnaissance de filiation doit pouvoir
engager au moins le débat sur la
reconnaissance et la légalisation de la
gpa en france
maty merci guillaume berleur mathilde
bretelles pour que le disais il ya
beaucoup de gens qui pensent comme elle
que façon dès lors qu'on fait la pma il
faudra faire la gpa
donc ceux qui disait attention si la
procréation médicalement assistée pour
les couples homosexuels pour les couples
de lesbiennes il y aura forcément la gpa
derrière au nom de l'égalité pour les
couples homosexuels même s'il additionne
la cour de cassation
c'est pour un couple hétérosexuel qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous bon écoutez
je vais jouer le rôle de l'empêcheur de
tourner en rond c'est un peu pour ça que
vous méritez pendant un an je jouais aux
infections ce jeu je crains que
malheureusement au nom des bons
sentiments qui est de régler la
situation des enfants qui seraient dans
une dans un état psychologique délicat
et bien en fait on ne crée les
conditions pour que les enfants soient
systématiquement traités comme des
marchandises
je crois que malheureusement il ya une
marchandisation de notre société
on n'est pas dans une société avec un
marché on études dans une société où
tout devient un marché possibles y
compris la grossesse d'une femme
l'exploitation effectivement de la femme
que l'on va utiliser même si elle est
consentante
enfin les enfants qui de 8 ans qui
travaillaient dans les mines étaient
consentants aussi au 19e siècle pour
pouvoir nourrir leurs familles mais
enfin il n'empêche que ont créé des
conditions pour que hill puis soit
obligé de le faire
bon le fait est que on a une évolution
de notre société dans laquelle dont le
fond ce qui compte c'est le désir le
désir des uns et des autres d'obtenir un
droit
je ne crois pas que le fait d'avoir un
enfant soit un droit on ne posait pas un
droit sur une personne on peut posséder
un droit sur une chose mais pas sur une
personne humaine et que donc par
conséquent je suis au regret de dire que
les personnes qui revendiquent font du
chantage à l'affectif
parce qu'ils ont obtenu une naissance à
l'étranger par le biais de la gpa qui
font du chantage affectif à la société
française
et bien ne prennent pas suffisamment en
considération la situation de l'enfant
qui est réduit qui est comme on dirait
ici et qui réduit à une chose et ça me
choque énormément
adriana tout c'est la question du jour
sur lefigaro.fr le voile sur la pma en
france va-t-il selon vous ouvrir la voie
à la gpa 84 % des internautes du figaro
qui ont voté en avait pas un sondage
disent que oui ils ont raison
alors juste avant que de petites
précisions guillaume bernard disait
qu'il est l'empêcheur de tourner en rond
mais je pense que gay ou votre position
sur le sujet n'est pas totalement de
marginal puisque il ya beaucoup de gens
dont je fais partie par ailleurs qu'ils
se sentent plus tôt peut-être de l'autre
bout de l'échiquier politique qui sont
de gauche qui sont qui ont des valeurs
peut-être un peu différente et qu'ils
ont complètement contrôle à gpa contre
ce qui me semble être le déploiement du
marché à tous les secteurs de la vie
dans le but d'accomplir des désirs
individuels
donc je pense que vous n'êtes pas seuls
ou isolé sur ce sujet maintenant si on
passe sur si on passera sur le fait que
la que la gpa un peu que la pma puisse
mener la gpa ce qui est sûr en tout cas
c'est que au sein de la république en
marche
il y a des des personnalités qui veulent
profiter entre guillemets de ce débat
qui est sur la filiation et sur la
l'ouverture de nouveaux droits pour
introduire la gpa vous on peut citer
nathalie l'oiseau par exemple qui a dit
qu'elle était favorable à une gpa
éthiques
aurélien dachier qui est quand même le
co animateur du pôle idées dans marche
qui est aussi favorable des députés
comme jean louis touraine olivier
ferrand voilà il ya des personnalités a
rappelé qu'en marche qui sont pour faire
avancer l'avancée vers la gpa il ya
aussi des personnes qui sont extrêmement
hostile mais en fait oui l'argument de
dire la pma
l'ouverture de la pma va ouvrir de fait
le débat sur la gpa c'est un argument
qui est valide oui puisque puisque la
pma va être ouverte
logiquement enfin puisqu'il ya une
majorité l'erreur n'y a pas de raison
que le texte soit pas votée la pma va
être ouverte aux couples enfin au fameux
salée aux couples homosexuels de femmes
le principe d'égalité elle va conduire à
ce que et bien pour les couples
homosexuels hommes et bien la gpa puisse
être ouvert en tout cas il ya une
certaine logique à à craindre
justement cette évolution la
laurentienne vous êtes sénatrice n'est
pas député mais si vous aviez été député
vous auriez voter et si l'amendement
revient au sénat ce qui peut arriver
tout à fait aussi moi je voterai contre
7,7 amendement je suis absolument
hostile à toute forme de légalisation de
la gpa en france et pour revenir sur la
question de durée des pommes de
raisonnement vous vous dites c'est la
pma qui va conduire par une question
d'égalité à ouvrir à la chanson pour
autrui
prenons la question autrement la pma est
une technique de procréation qui est
ouverte aujourd'hui aux couples
hétérosexuels
voilà elle est autorisée elle ne pose
auquel ne pose pas de problème éthique
ou bioéthique est pas vraiment ce qui
fait la grande la fécondation in vitro
il ya quand même un certain nombre
d'embryons créés et qui de fait louis
leurre d'enfant il ya quand même des
couronnes il ya des courants de pensée
qui trouve que la pma pose même pour les
couples hétérosexuels des problèmes
éthiques cds couvrant extrêmement
catholique religieux qui considèrent que
la vie commence tout de suite tout de
suite ddd la rencontre du spermatozoïde
et de levure et que l'on doit pas on
doit pas intervenir que dieu seul peut
décider qui n'est qu'ils meurent et
quand on est quand on l'ordre des choses
c'est nécessaire c'est logique bon ceci
dit nous vous considérez que c'est assez
marginal et qu'il ya des couples qui
rockets qui retrouvera la pma découpe et
euro série de recours à la pma qui sont
très nombreux et que personne n'ose
vraiment est hostile elles et leur dire
qu'ils avouent qu'ils ont tort ceci dit
comme cette technique est ouverte aux
couples hétérosexuels
c'est une inégalité de la refuser aux
femmes seules ou femme lesbienne
en ce qui concerne la gestation pour
autrui c'est interdit à tout le monde
hétéro homo personne ne peut accéder en
france avec à la gpa donc il faut s'en
tenir à ça pourquoi il faut s'en tenir à
ça tout en ayant en tête qui attaquent
des sujets la question de l'intérêt de
l'enfant n'est pas neutre et c'est pas
parce qu'on va légaliser la pma aboutir
à la gpa c'est simplement parce qu'il ya
des enfants ils sont là ses enfants
donc moi j'ai été confronté quand elle
était ministre chargé de l'enfance à la
question de les tests ville de la
transcription et comment on fait
aujourd'hui pour respecter à la fois le
droit de l'enfant à la vie privée qui
est une bien droit qui est garanti par
la convention des droits de l'enfant le
droit de l'enfant à une famille le droit
à une famille et en même temps ne pas
banaliser ces couples et faciliter la
leur recours à la gpa parce que la gpa
moi je veux bien tout âge et perry tic
j'y crois pas une seconde je pense que
c'est une énorme mystification toutes
les femmes qui sur la planète
choisissent de faire mère-porteuse le
font pour des raisons économiques vous
allez dans les usines à bébés en inde
vous allez dans les usines à bébés en 1
qu'est ce que vous disent les femmes qui
font mère porteuse que les femmes sont
tellement pauvres en inde qu'avec ça
elles vont pouvoir payer des études et
leurs enfants vous êtes on vient de
démanteler une usine à bébés au nigeria
c'était sordide et quant aux pays qui
ont légalisé comme les états unis où
certains états unis ou au canada
pardonnez moi mais là encore ce qu'on
appelle une indemnité est en réalité de
rémunération et j'ajoute en plus que ça
pose des problèmes de droit extrêmement
lourd qu'on connaît et qui se sont
produits parce qu'aider gpa sur la
planète y en a par exemple l'emploi le
feu tu sais malformés ma le couple la
tension n'en veut plus
donc acquis qui va s'occuper du bébé le
couple les intentions demande d'un
avortement
il se trouve que la mère porteuse est
hostile à l'avortement et dit moi je
fais pas ça qui va s'occuper du bébé les
conventions que j'ai pas il faut lire
une convention de gpa dans un pays
développés comme les états unis le
canada la maire s'engage la mère
porteuse s'engage à ne pas avoir de
relations sexuelles pendant la grossesse
pas fumer pas boire c'est encore on peut
trouver que c'est pas trop choquant mais
il ya un contrôle sur la grossesse et le
corps de cette femme dont on voit en fin
de compte que la gpa ce n'est jamais
qu'une nouvelle façon de s'approprier la
fonction des la fonction des femmes qui
est une fonction génitrice
et une fois de plus on est dans le
contrôle et la com et la marchandisation
du corps des femmes
alors moi je ne suis pas humble enfance
et on prévoit qu'il faut l'éliminer s'il
est mal formés ou ce qu'il a dit ça
encore c'est plutôt que ten des
problèmes de droit contre c'est qu'on ne
sait pas résoudre mais surtout on
admettrait là que les femmes en fin de
compte sont envoyées à leur fonction
première
faire des bébés et maintenant elle le
ferait avec la gpa pour contre
rémunération se fait bien le job
pourquoi pas aussi mettre des petites
annonces un pur à pôle emploi peut
parents d'intention cherchent non c'est
pas possible
voilà ce n'est pas possible d'abord il
ya quand même plusieurs choses c'est à
dire que la gpl et pas toujours avec une
compensation financière
je me rappelle quand même que par
exemple au royaume uni c'est tout à fait
possible mais ça ne peut se faire que
pardon d'abord et ensuite
non nous on assume tout à fait l'aspect
financier d'ailleurs ce qu'on propose
c'est que la personne qui soit femmes
porteuses et non par mère porteuse soit
dans une situation économique qui ne
soit pas une situation de nécessité et
ensuite vous parliez des contrats je
vous rappelle qu'il ya autant de
contrats qui lient à de gpa puisque il
l'est chaque partie prenante que ce soit
le couple où la femme porteuse
à chacun son avocat avec un en
établissant ensemble des contrats en
parallèle où chacun se met d'accord
et enfin je trouve que c'est quand même
je me permets là dessus c'est que je
trouve que c'est compliqué de dire pour
toutes les femmes
on décide qu'elle ne sont pas capables
de prendre
cette décision de manière libre et
éclairé avant que l'ag avant que la gpa
soit interdite en france en 1994 de
mémoire il y avait un vide juridique
à l'époque en france et donc comme dans
certains pays actuellement c'était ni
légale ni légal et donc ça a eu lieu il
ya plusieurs témoignages qui sont
ressortis qui dont une femme notamment
le témoignage en tête a écrit qui disait
que l donc elle avait été femme porteuse
et qu'elle l'avait fait voilà comme ça
totalement volontairement parce que pour
elle la base de la société humaine celle
entraide que l avez la possibilité de
pouvoir porter des enfants et qu'elle
l'avait fait mais avec tout l'amour du
monde pour et tout le tout le plaisir du
monde de pouvoir offrir à des parents
qui ont un projet d'enfant un projet de
vie avec un enfant et qui ne peuvent pas
l'avoir de pouvoir le faire pour donc je
trouve que réduire à une marchandisation
du corps et avait un marché du bébé
c'est quand même sexuels qu'il faut
retranscrire la série il a de plus jugé
à quelque chose parce que
psychologiquement l'enfant serait dans
une position délicate mais en revanche
le fait qu'il sache qu'il a été le
résultat d'un contrat de travail ça
psychologiquement ça ne lui porterait
pas préjudice non mais bien contre haye
est passé bien d'ailleurs
il faut quand même sécuriser les enfants
et on est dans une situation juridique
qui est compliqué c'est moi tu quand je
fais les interrompt ce débat est
passionnant mais on avait d'autres
thèmes qu'on avait envie de d'aborder
même si on a passé le tout le temps qui
est je pense qu'il est utile et
intéressant pour vous chers internautes
en tout cas on le souhaite sur ce sujet
quelques commentaires citoyens payeurs
qui louent 17 gpa passera puisque cela
semble une priorité des progressistes
avec toutes les guillemets qui
s'imposent et daniel qui dit mais le
progressisme de relève qu'il parle d'une
auto proclamation et qui dit que le
progrès représente une amélioration
c'est un beau sujet si je ne cède rien
que la gpa sera légalisé dans le
prochain mandat et peut être même
remboursé par la sécu et on verra si ces
derniers rebondissements motive les
manifestants qui doivent être dans les
rues de paris dimanche prochain contre
le projet de loi bioéthique